Того дня вранці я говорила мамі, що щось буде недобре, бо дуже часті повітряні тривоги…
У цей день 14 числа, як не дивно, ми будували плани на півроку вперед. Був просто дивовижний настрій.
Батьки сказали мені "іди вже відпочивати" - це буквально хвилин 10 було, коли я відклала телефон поруч з собою.
Лягла, закуталася, щоб засинати вже, і я почула якийсь гуркіт.
Вимкнули світло, вимкнули інтернет. І чоловік мене кличе в сусідню кімнату…
Ми беремо ковдру, накриваємося і буквально за десять хвилин сталося те, що сталося.
Через цю фотографію Анастасію іноді впізнають на вулиці.
Вона одна з тих, хто вижив після прильоту в житловий будинок у Дніпрі 14 січня.
Це останні фото з моїм котом, із залишками моєї квартири, коли ти дивишся і розумієш, що все було добре, у тебе була сім'я, у тебе був свій будинок…
Насті 24 роки, вона жила разом з мамою, татом і котом на вулиці Набережна Перемоги.
Коли російська ракета влучила в їхній будинок, дівчина була у спальній кімнаті, а батьки - на кухні.
Я просто дивлюся в бік свого коридору, і розумію, що бачу сусідній під'їзд.
А ми його ніяк не можемо бачити з квартири.
І я розумію, що будинку більше немає.
Розумію, що мої батьки на той момент були на кухні разом, я починаю кричати, кликати їх, розумію, що кухні взагалі немає.
У суботу це трапилося, і десь по обіді в неділю я дізналася, що батьків знайшли, дістали з-під завалів, вони загинули разом.
У вересні торік Настя пережила ще одну втрату.
Під час контрнаступу на Харківщині загинув її хлопець Владислав, який пішов воювати добровольцем.
Це були дуже жахливі для мене дні і тижні, бо я взагалі не вставала з ліжка, я нічого не їла, я ні з ким не розмовляла,
мати майже заново вчила мене ходити, бо я не хотіла вставати з ліжка, для мене життя на той момент закінчилося.
І наразі мені здається, може, тому що я вже знаю, як переживати цю втрату,
мені трохи легше переживати втрату батьків.
Тому що я ще не змирилася з цією втратою, і тут вже немає батьків…
Після трагедії Настя живе у родичів, має відпустку за лікарняним, незабаром хоче повернутися на роботу в пекарню.
Дівчині досі лячно від повітряних тривог, доводиться приймати заспокійливе. Але вона впевнена, що життя триває.
Якщо я зараз впаду в депресію, я буду лежати і ридати щодня, життя від цього не зміниться. Не одній мені важко і боляче.
Я розумію, що треба рухатися далі.
Я розумію, що якщо мені дароване друге життя, другий день народження, то я для чогось тут ще потрібна,
і я маю продовжувати жити тут не тільки для себе і за себе, а й продовжувати життя за своїх батьків.
Я буду рости, я буду розвиватися і буду намагатися, щоб їхні життя і справи були недаремними.
З психологом Ольгою, яка жила в тому ж будинку, ми зустрічаємося неподалік її нового житла.
Квартиру Ользі і її чоловіку надали незнайомі люди.
Люди, таке враження, що об'єдналися всі у велику суперсилу, і цю суперсилу, як вайфай, передавали нам.
Усе, що в мене зараз є, в нашій сім'ї, це все дали люди.
І одяг, і фінансова допомога, і підтримка, і квартира.
Це відео Ольга встигла зняти одразу після ракетного удару. У її квартирі на дев'ятому поверсі вціліла лише спальня,
де саме відпочивали вони з чоловіком Євгеном.
Жінка отримала травму голови, але чоловік вчасно зупинив кровотечу і подавав сигнали ліхтариком з вікна, аби рятувальники швидше його помітили.
Для Ольги і Євгена це не перше випробування.
У 2014 році вони виїхали з Донецька до Херсона.
Навесні торік - довелося залишити й це окуповане росіянами місто.
Тому наша сім'я обнуляється уже втретє, починає життя спочатку.
Найдивовижніше: 14 січня був наш другий день народження, я це вважаю нашим другим днем народження...
А 15 числа нам дзвонять сусіди з нашого будинку, який у Херсоні, там зовсім небагато людей залишилося, на жаль,
через ситуацію, і прилітає ще одна новина - у нашу квартиру, в наш будинок в Херсоні, теж прилетіла ракета.
Тому що сказати…
Таке життя. Але у нас є можливість жити, є ми. А матеріальне, думаю, з часом прийде.
Якщо вищі сили дали нам шанс залишитися живими вдвох і цей шанс жити,
то я не маю жодного морального права опускати руки, зрошувати подушку слізьми.
І це мені дає стимул жити далі. Я розумію, що кожен день - це велике диво.
Життя - це диво. І кожен день - це можливість іти далі і жити.
І вона в мене є, на відміну від людей, які перебували в цьому будинку.
Які так само будували плани, які ростили дітей, планували життя на довгі роки.
Ця можливість є у мене! І я думаю, що правильно не втрачати цю можливість.